you
ivorie one is cherry amount Ches calm
right now and I'd like to share two
in-game puzzles with you from tactics
trainer both are white to move and so as
usual feel free to treat this as a mini
pop quiz so if you'd like to go ahead
pause the video see if you can find the
best continuation for what okay the
solution to this first one is to play
rook to d4 on move one let me just cover
quickly one what if Bishop e2 may be
tempting on move one setting up a double
checkmate but black is on move has a
discovered check and connects to play
king c5 and there isn't a good way
forward for white y can still pick up
the Queen but by this point white is
having white has to invest too much
material black is winning this
so the key first move as mentioned is
rook D form king c5 and now a unique
clearance tactic sacrificing the rook
rook takes d5 clearing the way for what
after pawn takes is otherwise we pick up
the Queen after pawn takes we now have
the move d4 controlling the dark square
controlling c5 and now regardless of
where the King goes King c6 runs into a
skewer tactic Bishop ei t' picking up
the queen or if the King goes in the
other direction similarly we have Bishop
e2 now picking up the Queen if this one
was carried out a bit more just to show
here's how you can convert this white
will be there in time to stop the beep
on and soon run with the D pawn so I
thought that that one was pretty neat
and also one more this one right here
once more whites move if you'd like to
go ahead and pause the video see if you
can find the best continuation
okay I really like this one it's uh some
unique features to this one and at the
very tail end of it a nice practical tip
regarding King and pawn end games so
there is only one way to win this and
that is to start out with Bishop to d3
let me just once more cover a what if
for this puzzle if you try and take off
with the pond the King steps off of EA
he approaches the pond he will be there
in time to stop the pond why did I draw
some reference to the King stepping off
of the e8 square well the move Bishop d3
looks to take advantage of the current
king post what is the idea well there's
one way that the rook can try to slip
away and that is by way of a six let's
say a1 and then get behind the pond but
you can't do that just yet because of
Bishop takes pawn with the fork making
use of the king position okay but
suppose black sees this and says I'm not
going to play rook a6 just yet I'm gonna
get out of this little tactic and play
King to f7 now what do we do well we
still capture the pawn this is the key
idea this is a clever shot right here to
take on b5 and what's the idea after
rook takes Bishop we're down
pretty much a rook but the rook is very
short on squares King C for King B rook
to b6 and now B 5 the rook is stuck the
best that black can do is hunt down the
H han but once we come over to a5 we're
ready to win a free ruck now so black
might as well grab a pawn rook takes
King takes and who's gonna win the race
let's see we arrive now at a very
important point in King and pawn end
games and that's this one right here
where we have an instance of fixed pawns
to fixed pawns or what some may describe
as a ram structure why does on move and
it's extremely important you pick the
correct Square to go to when approaching
the pawns the correct idea the only win
in this position is to play king c7 or
in other words to attack your opponent's
pawn but not defend your own pun this is
very important we want to attack our
opponent's pawn and not defend our own
pun why is this important well if we do
both if we attack our opponent's pawn
and defend our own after now King a 5
we have to move away from defending our
d5 pawn black picks up the pawn black
goes on to win so Tempe in King and pawn
end games extremely important perfect
example right here
King c7 King a 5 and only now king c6 in
its black who has to move away from
defending their own pond in white will
go on to win so a nice little endgame
tip regarding the you know King and pawn
endgame positions in this puzzle but
overall these were a couple meets and
game puzzles in my estimation feel free
to share how you did with these two as
usual in the comments section below
and I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now
take care bye
you
[Music]